now to politics democrat joe biden now  officially has nevada's six electoral  college votes  this morning nevada's electors met  virtually as you see here to complete  the process  electors cast their ballots you see  there they held them up so they could be  seen by everybody watching  it's all a constitutional process and  it's taking place today all across the  country  one of the last steps to formalize the  presidential election  the president-elect biden projected to  receive about 306 electoral college  votes  president trump 232 that will officially  be tallied by congress january 6.  president trump and his supporters  though they are still pursuing legal  options to try and overturn the results